the cost of War families and homes torn
to shreds and a big pissed-off lizard
Godzilla minus one has it all here's a
breakdown to the ending of too's
fantastic Kaiju Blockbuster like the
original 1954 film Godzilla minus one is
a war movie even though it mostly takes
place after the end of World War II in
the opening scene we meet koichi
shikishima a Japanese kamakazi pilot who
abandons his Squadron under false
pretenses of mechanical trouble he lands
at the air base on Odo Island fearing
that the other soldiers will condemn him
as a coward however the command the base
actually supports him saying that it's
foolish to die when Japan seems destined
to lose the war that night the entire
base is wiped out by Godzilla kichi has
a chance to shoot the monster but he
panics leaving him a mechanic Tachi bana
as the only survivors scorned by
tachibana for his cowardice kuichi
returns home after the war to find his
Tokyo neighborhood decimated by American
bombings in the reubel he meets noro a
young woman caring for an orphan baby
named Akiko the three form a kind of
family while koichi Gets a Job
dismantling mines off the coast of Japan
in a montage we see that Godzilla is
mutated by the nuclear weapons test at
bikini ATL and begins attacking us ships
he eventually reaches Japan where he
destroys more ships and lays ways to
Tokyo's ginsa District seemingly killing
norico in the process devastated koichi
joins a civilian effort to kill the
Beast volunteering to serve his baits
while flying an untested experimental
aircraft from the war because the
Japanese military was disarmed following
World War II there's very little to stop
Godzilla's Rampage in the absence of
Armed Force Dr Kenji Nota devises a
complex plan to defeat the Beast he
intends to lure Godzilla out into a deep
area of water wrap him up in cables
laced with pron tanks and use them to
drop the monster 1500 M down if the
rapid change in pressure doesn't kill
him flotation devices will be deployed
to bring Godzilla back up to the surface
further wreaking havoc on his body as
Nota helps organize the civilian Navy
mostly consisting of former soldiers
demand the necessary ships kuichi
enlists tachibana to modify his shindin
fighter plane if all else fails he
plants the fly into Godzilla's jaw Paws
hopefully destroying his brain and
killing him with a mouthful of
explosives none of this makes Godzilla
any
happier the plan plays out smoothly with
kuichi and his plane leading Godzilla
out to the Target location the freon
canisters fail to do the job though and
the Kaiju choose to the flotation
devices at 800 M when they pull him back
up all seems lost but in the hour of
Despair a whole Fleet of tugboats
arrives to help yank the monster to the
surface Dr Nota and the other older men
take the responsibility for the attack
on Godzilla upon the M themselves all
survivors of the war they see the Beast
as a remnant of that violence left
unfinished though the young shirou wants
to come with them they order him to stay
behind of course it's shirou who leads
the tugboat charge the dedication of the
former soldiers while well placed isn't
enough to fully defeat Godzilla it's no
accident that they require assistance
from the useless as shirou calls them
those who never fought in the War to
literally pull them out for Japan to
move on and properly begin rebuilding
the movie seems to say it will take a
combined effort from the survivors and
those who represent the future right
right as aaiu is charging up his Atomic
heat ray kuichi flies into Godzilla's
mouth and detonates the payload kuichi
survives having used the ejector seat to
jump to safety in a happy twist kichi
returns home to a telegram revealing
that noro is actually still alive the
chaos in the Ginza attack left many
victims injured and lost with no way to
identify them it seems that this fate
also befell noro who sustained wounds
from Godzilla's heat ray blast but
survived after being taken to a hospital
kuichi rushes to her bedside with Akiko
in his arms and the family is reunited
noro asks if koichi's war is finally
over and he breaks down crying clutching
her to his body and declaring that yes
it finally is of course it isn't all
sunshine and rainbows as a happy reunion
Fades out the camera shifts suspiciously
to noro's neck with a faint design of
something dark can be seen undela
beneath the skin this could simply be
some kind of ordinary radiation
poisoning but with Godzilla still being
an unknown quantity in this Incarnation
it could also be a sign of something
more Sinister perhaps noro is exposed to
some kind of Godzilla DNA or G cells as
they've often been called in previous
movies such an infection might have even
helped her survive her injuries for now
though there's too little evidence to
say for certain what's happening to her
hopefully the little family has
weathered enough tragedies but when it
comes to Godzilla of course the threat
is never really gone the final shot at
the end of Godzilla minus one is an
ominous one the camera jumps to the
depths of the sea where a moled chunk of
Godzilla's body begins to regenerate on
its own the shot doesn't necessarily
mean that a sequel is coming in fact
it's pretty common for Godzilla FS to
end with the promise of the monster's
return there will always be another
Godzilla film be it a direct sequel or
yet another reboot and one of the Kaiju
defining traits is that he never stays
down for long still given the critical
success of Godzilla minus one and its
widespread US release it could also
become the first Toho entry in two
decades to get a proper sequel the
dominant message of Godzilla minus one
is clear living is the real Victory any
supposed accomplishment that
necessitates death any great sacrifice
in the name of Fame honor or fortune
pales in comparison into the simple
victory of living to build a new for
most of the movie kichi is racked by
guilt calling himself someone who wasn't
supposed to live he goes to Great
Lengths to bring in Tachi bana to fix
the shindin because he wants Absolution
he wants to look the man who called him
a coward in the eyes and declare that
he's willing to die this time but after
kuichi flies to shindin into Godzilla we
see tabana listening at the radio with
baited breath only when he hears that
kuichi is still alive does he exhale his
own War seems to have been ended by the
act of forgiveness and the choice to
live in fact not a single human dies
during the final attack against Godzilla
a decoy Destroyer is blown up but every
other craft remains intact unlike the
war it's not a battle to the death it's
a battle for life and for the future in
his best films Godzilla has always been
a symbol most frequently a walking
embodiment to the destructive power of
nuclear weapons or an avatar for the
punishment Japan received after World
War
II that's certainly part of his
characterization in minus one but the
film makes the king of the monsters more
complicated than that writer director
tekashi amazaki recently told vulture
Godzilla is more of an undiscerning God
in Japan it's integrated into Shinto
belief all of these negative things in
the world have manifested themselves
into Godzilla and us as humans we not
out to kill Godzilla but were're able to
calm Godzilla and bring ourselves back
to peace the Kaiju was arguably it as
most terrifying ever in minus one with a
heat ray that detonates like a nuclear
warhead and a roar that follows every
brutal attack Godzilla doesn't just seem
angry at Humanity he seems angry at
simply being alive it's a rage that
reflects koichi's own survivors guilt a
feeling of discomfort with the gift of
life it's not just the atomic bomb that
has summoned the monster in this version
of the story but the combined grief
anger violence and shame that those who
escaped the war left with defeating
Godzilla means putting those things to
rest and finally choosing to live for
the future that's why the former
soldiers need the younger generation to
help them win in the end and it's the
reason that the true victory for kichi
means surviving his final attack the
emotional core of Godzilla minus one is
unique family dynamic between kuichi
noro and Akiko they first meet by sheer
hapim stance and kuichi quickly learns
that Akiko isn't even noro's baby just
the child of a Dying woman who asked
noro to take care of her then Sumo jumps
in and is sort of a surrogate aunt or
grandmother it's a family that would
have never been formed had any of the
adults simply chosen to act selfishly
but the result is a happy stable home
albe it one still haunted by kui's
lingering trauma by the end of Godzilla
minus one kuichi finally puts those
demons to rest this strange forsome
seems indicative of the larger
reconstruction movement shown throughout
the film pretty much everyone we meet in
the movie lost someone in the war and
yet faced with what feels like
insurmountable grief they build a new
community and push forward in a midm
movie montage we see the bombed out
house where koichi's family once lived
slowly rebuilt it's this Defiance in the
face of Devastation this passion for a
better future that helps these
characters make it through writer
director tekashi amazaki has spoken
extensively about his goals for Godzilla
minus one in the films that inspired it
he told movie phone regarding past
Godzilla films sometimes the story is
told where you switch to Godzilla and
then you switch to the human story and
they end up kind of existing
independently but I really wanted to
make sure that they were intertwined in
a balanced way so that the human drama
and whatever is going on with Godzilla
had the right balance asked about the
lasting impact of Godzilla yamazaki
explained his perspective on what the
creature represents culturally saying
it's a concept of an animal or object
absorbing so much evil energy or the
negativity of the world that it takes
shape this needs a cycle every couple of
decades think maybe it's just the timing
that we need to be reminded and go
through the exercise of visualizing your
worries evils and whatever's going on in
the
world nothing can save the city now the
ending of Godzilla minus one practically
begs for a sequel and with all the
praise that the human characters in the
movie have gotten from critics and
viewers it would be great to see the
cast return for a follow-up but How
likely is that toou hasn't made a proper
liveaction sequel to a Godzilla movie
since 2003 when Godzilla Tokyo SOS
followed up the story of the previous
years's Godzilla against Mecca Godzilla
only three live-action Godzilla films
have been released by Tojo since then
2004's Godzilla final wars 2016's Shin
Godzilla and now minus one each of those
projects acts as an independent story
with no shared continuity between them
in short Toho has been stingier than
ever over the last two decades when it
comes to the king of the monsters that
makes the chances of a minus one sequel
look slim but there is hope thanks in
part to the success of legendaries
monster riverse films Godzilla has had
somewhat of an international Resurgence
and with minus one receiving a wide
release in North America too could be
testing the waters for more frequent
Productions going forward it's all up in
the air for now but even if no sequel
arrives Godzilla minus one has gifted
fans with one of the greatest Kaiju
movies ever and one of the best films of
[Music]